oh I didn't even pick that one all right
Joe Biden trying to sell Americans on
the crap sandwich he calls by Dynamics
the key ingredients being soaring
inflation that's got family spending 700
dollars more per month than two years
ago I won't be able to afford my top
surgery Dana
living paycheck to paycheck is becoming
the new Norm
of surging gas prices the president is
cronies doubting the one-year birthday
of his inflation reduction act named the
big guy regrets since it's more of a
bloated climate slush fund
Mr President this is your day this is
your day Mr President introduced the
first climate bill in the Senate 1986.
before I was in Congress you already
here this was such an amazing effort
to pass one of the great legislative
Feats of the 20th century 21st century
probably of the 20th too
the financial times in the Wall Street
Journal initially call my plan binomics
I'm not sure that many of them totally
complimentary way at the time
but guess what
[Applause]
you know um it's a year later he's kind
of like doesn't like the name of it
because it really didn't reduce
inflation you know he wishes he relied
better he wished he had lied better
exactly but you know you have to give
him credit where credit is due at least
he's admitting that he's been lying for
a year yes and it was alive from the
beginning and they knew it and the only
reason they're doing it is because
they've seen the polls and the polling
is terrible and you know and and I
always hate these statistics like you go
to the depart the department Department
of Labor or the BLS and get all these
you don't need statistics from a federal
department to know that people are
paying way more at the grocery store
people are getting we're getting close
to four dollars a gallon of gasoline
um and this is all and and of course why
do demo you know why did Joe Biden want
to talk about the environment the first
place why does he want the green New
Deal in the first place which by the way
let's not forget the green New Deal uh
which cratered American Energy
Independence and allowed Vladimir Putin
to invade Ukraine um why is it that they
want to talk about the environment it's
because they can't fix anything that
actually matters the people actually
care about so they're going to fix the
weather and something tells me they're
not going to work at that um
it's not gonna work
judge don't you feel bad for the media
people like Joseph Karloff who parodied
the hilarious lie that it was about
taxes and now their supreme leader says
it wasn't that at all I'd feel pretty
bad if I was like
[Laughter]
part of it is he says himself I wish I
hadn't called it the inflation reduction
act and he knew immediately that it
wasn't going to reduce inflation because
the CBO came out and said this has
nothing to do with inflation so it
wasn't like a mistake it was an out and
out lie where it was nothing more than a
contribution to Green energy and all
this other stuff that he wanted to uh
that he wanted to fund so the question
is why did he lie in the first place
he's lying about everything since he
came on the scene whether it had to do
with his grades whether it had to do
with uh you know whether he worked in
the coal mines like who was it Neil
kinnick that British uh poet and he had
to drop out of a presidential race
because he lied this guy's lied his
whole life he lied when he said he knew
nothing about his son's oversea the guy
is a liar so given all that here's the
issue the issue is that 51 of Americans
think the economy is getting worse and
the truth is that 34 percent approve of
his handling of the economy now what I
did which I thought was interest because
I hate math is you take a guy or a
family that's making fifty five thousand
dollars a year now we know that 709
dollars a month goes to inflation so you
figure that out for a year and you know
that guy who makes fifty five thousand
dollars a year that family now only
makes forty six thousand dollars a year
that's phytonomics at its best and
that's not a lie
yeah Jessica it costs 709 bucks more to
live the way you lived before Biden was
in office and as a pansexual I
you know I am deeply offended because
how can I act in a pansexual manner when
I'm when I'm out of money do you even
know what that would mean yes the fewer
pans
okay
so
I understand why he wants to change what
he called it because he isn't getting
the Kudos that he deserves for the
climate agenda aspect of this I think
it's 380 billion dollars worth of
investment and struggling with younger
voters who have not latched on to that
and identified it but the elephant in
the room is the actual inflation numbers
and I understand that it's a marriage
between policy and what's going on in
the fed and the interest rates are up
but we started with over nine percent
inflation at this point last year now
it's a 3.2 percent before you say it's
still too high grocery prices I get all
of it I too eat and go to the grocery
store but we do have the lowest
inflation of the G7 in general this is a
global problem just much like the issue
with Energy prices was when Russia
invaded Ukraine which had nothing to do
with green No Deal which hasn't even
been enacted but there are these markers
out there like if everything is so
terrible for instance why does Bank of
America Goldman Sachs JP Morgan all say
we're not going to have a recession now
when they thought that we would why is
the unemployment rate so low why are we
gaining this many jobs I mean there are
anchors who've been on our own network
talking about this completely
flabbergasted live on air when the jobs
numbers come in they say oh my God this
is incredible what we're seeing revising
up by hundreds of thousands and so
you're even surprised when it goes well
I'm just imitating an anchor that was
surprised I knew it was happening
this one was
um but also the inflation reduction act
has had a lot of tangible results that
Republicans are really happy with like
Tim Scott for instance has been bragging
about the investment from this company
Redwood materials coming to South
Carolina when you ask Redwood materials
why they came they said the benefits of
the inflation reduction act that's what
it did it gave incentives to companies
Dana Dana's starting to squirm no well a
couple of things on that so
um it is true that some a lot of these
companies that are getting money from
this big gigantic Bill are deciding to
go into red States why oh because the
cost of living is better the tax base is
better there are more employees that are
there and that's why so all the I think
that in a way a lot of these Democrats
like shoot what did we do here why
doesn't anybody want to come and live in
our state well that's the reason why
um Joe Biden couldn't call this bill the
largest climate giveaway in history
because it wouldn't pass the Congress
hashtag never forget Senator Joe manchin
is the one who got the bill passed right
and remember he twisted himself into not
skinny version and he was like okay this
is really about reducing inflation and
it wasn't and so don't forget that if he
decides to run for president
um the other thing is it's interesting
on I just learned this the other day
that historically when you go up to a
presidential election people look
backwards on the economy like they
remember what it was like when gas
prices were at five dollars a gallon and
they're like that will never happen
again to me they they for some reason
it's very difficult for for a current
president to say no look it's getting
better and Goldman Sachs says in eight
months we're not going to have a
recession and people are just like don't
hear that for some reason last thing I
would say is they're trying at the White
House to tell people how they should
feel rather than dealing with how they
already feel and that's a loser yeah
excellent point Dan thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else